- You guys are looking for Gary V
general admission right
here VIP over there.
- I'm lookin' for him.
(laughter)
- General admission right
here VIP over there.
We're not lettin' people in yet.
- This is Gary V.
- I am Gary V.
(laughter)
How you doin"?
- As good as I been vlog,
goin' to Hugh Lodge, The Voice,
fuckin' sunshine in
Los Angeles, real good.
Iris, where are you?
It's unbelievable, we'd
much rather eat soil
than smell roses.
That's why we have so many roses.
- Thanks man.
- Take care of yourself.
- You're so inspiring bro,
- Thank you very much.
- Swear to God.
- You're the most inspirational guy.
- Congratulations
- Thank you
- We're in complex times.
- Rappers?
- These are just good human beings.
Ferg overslept, so now I
gotta go on 11:15 solo.
When impact is your
motivation you could be calm.
I like the people waitin' in
line tryin' to make that money.
You know what this reminds me of?
It's baseball card
shows, that's all it is.
It's just patience man.
Fuckin' hard ass work,
listening to absolutely nobody
and everybody wants to listen
to other people's opinions
it's all fuckin' mistakes.
You have one big thing they don't have.
If one fuckin' persons in there.
I am going to fuckin' bring
it as hard as I fuckin' can.
This is a serious fuckin'
event, that people are going to
realize really matters.
- I'm 19 years old, I
fuckin' hate college.
I fuckin' hate school.
- So fuckin' call their
bluff, work at Burger King,
live with nine for...
Life's about options bro.
Dude I was makin' 34 thousand
dollars a year at 26.
You're not gonna fuckin' make me sob.
This guy, this is his natural talent,
this is natural talent.
For all the rest of us,
we've got to fucking grind,
we're not all blessed.
I am dropping my fucking
case with class...
Before you.
I was too scared that you
were going to get it first.
He was just makin' business
decisions, if you can't
afford fuckin' future,
you can't afford future.
No! This is the sweeper window,
get to the sweeper window.
(cheers)
- How do I get the confidence
to get back on the horse?
- There's no fuckin' choice.
You've gotta do what
the fuck you wanna do.
99% of influencers go for
the cash, never waiver.
Almost everybody wants it faster.
Most of the people here
aren't where they're at
because they did actions
that were predicated
on lack of patience.
Hot Ones community, I love you.
Even the 7,000 of you
that said I am the worst
piece of shit, that's
why I replied to you,
because I got love for you.
Dude, can you throw that
phone on the ground?
Take a photo.
Could you ever imagine what
you and I do for a living,
being an entrepreneur?
We cross over to what
he does for a living.
You're not stopping.
- I want what you got -
you stop when you die, man.
- I learn a whole lot from you,
I pastor a church in Miami.
Thank you sir, I appreciate you.
- I appreciate the love, man.
Hey, keep doing your thing.
"Post production".
I don't like dialing back, the
question is, do you have to?
The quickest way to never
buy the Porsche company
is to buy a Porche.
'Sup my man?
- How are you man?
- Keep doing your thing, man.
- Thank you bro.
- It's fun to watch.
- I appreciate that!
- Such good vibes.
- I'm so glad I'm fun to watch
- How are you?
It's my sweeper, my first
entrepreneur collaboration.
- That's so cool!
- Man's eatin' popcorn like a boss!
Never do something for somebody else.
Be you period, end of story.
- Why?
- Because you will be more
hungry to make it the next year.
- Oh my God, I am.
- Patience, my man,
- Hey Rock, get this
guy's info for this whole
"Global thing I've got" idea.
It's just all so good, like
what the fuck do we have
to complain about?
The wine guys are here.
(laughter)
Look at these guys.
- I made this for you Gary.
It's a piece I call The Good Challenge.
- I'm a big fan of your shit.
The champion right here, you don't know.
Get on who this man is.
This is fuckin' legit, thank you brother.
We need to exercise tomorrow.
Everybody here's making
bad decisions always.
That's gonna kill, kill!
- How you doin'?
- Good to see you.
- Shawn
- Everybody walkin' around
here that's never been punched
in the face, they're still vulnerable.
Imagine that shit happened to you at 37?
Eric Moose, he's my
favorite from everybody.
- 301 for life.
- Yo, upgrade your fuckin' software.
In the fuckin' dome, not your phone.
- Not your fuckin' phone baby.
- Get it, one life.
- By showin' patience, remember
I'm going to fuckin' die,
practicality, all that
shit, happenin' right now.
- Yes! If you're willing to bleed.
If you're willing to be humble.
Work!
Reboot your operating system,
it's in the dome not the phone.
You either have money or you have time.
Everybody's fancy and
doesn't want to fuckin' be
at a hundred people.
Is it 5:30? Second floor?
The Studio
5:30 The Complex Studio, it's goin' down.
The Q and A session, come see
me if you are at Complex Con.
All that WWF wrestling promotion
shit watchin' came through.
I'll tell you right now, there's
not one fuckin' group here
that had the right concept.
They just kept iterating what
they did, they did, they did.
- That guy right there is
a fuckin' genius everybody.
- Thank you brother. Thank you.
Big Crit, this guy's new
project, do not sleep on this.
- Don't sleep, you heard it from Gary V.
- How you doin'?
- I love you.
- I love you too.
- It's all the same shit,
self awareness, what are you
good at, patience, gratitude, hard work.
It's just beginning, you're
not even in the parking lot yet
to the fuckin' game,
to the national anthem.
Like, you've just started.
- I'm eatin' lunch with
the scalpers outside.
(laughter)
- I'm telling you, just pick one.
Just pick one, you're not
gonna know how it would've
worked out anyway.
Stop bullshitting and
start doin' somethin'.
I'll get you fuckin' mental fit,
because you've got one fuckin'
life, stop bullshittin' it.
I might be in Atlanta the
day after Thanksgiving.
You'll never regret
fuckin' making that punch.
So much progress for both of us.
Not even a year.
- You're unbelievable.
- Vlog, thank you Barney,
you're unbelievable
for seeing it for reaching out.
- What's your goal for 2018?
- I just want to be better
than I was the year before,
as a person, as an executor,
as an entrepreneur,
as a personality, as a dad, just better.
- Tell the people they're gonna die?
- Oh, I know they're gonna die,
it's what they're gonna do about it.
Do something.
You can't make up a narrative,
either you played Spades
and Cielo or you didn't.
Either you lived in the
environment we lived in
or you didn't.
It was like my Puff Daddy.
The mmms are comin' in.
I was about to sit down
because mmms are like,
oh shit, I better say
something else fuckin' fresh.
I haven't even talked about
mmms before I sit the fuck down.
I better come over a little more fresh.
Nobody is giving a fuck about
a supreme backpack when your
health isn't goin' anywhere.
Thank you guys so much, I
have nothin' but love for you.
(cheering)
Uh oh, look at this Vlog, double fisted.
Double fisted on the Vlog.
Good day guys today.
Pretty good, right?
We hacked a little culture, today.
I was in a different head-space in there.
- It was great when you said
all the nine to 11 entrepeneurs
- All the hat?
- All the nine to 11...
(laughter)
(music)
- That was some good content.